Traductor: Emma Gon
Revisor: Paula Motter
¿Qué es tan grande como un oso polar,
engulle a su presa entera
y nada a casi 65 km por hora?
No es un tiburón ni una orca,
sino el atún rojo del Atlántico.
Es el atún más grande y longevo
de las 15 especies que hay.
El atún rojo del Atlántico
tiene una serie única de adaptaciones
que lo hace el depredador
más dominante del océano.
Nace como una diminuta cría en
el golfo de México o el mar Mediterráneo,
no más grande que una pestaña humana.
En el primer año de vida,
desarrolla lo que se denomina
“endotermia regional”:
la habilidad de regular
su temperatura corporal.
El atún del Atlántico obtiene el oxígeno
del agua fría del mar con sus agallas.
Este proceso enfría su sangre.
Luego, el calor generado por el atún
al nadar y cazar calienta su sangre.
En la mayoría de los peces, este calor
se perdería en el mar por las agallas.
Pero en el atún del Atlántico,
un mecanismo llamado “intercambiador
de contracorriente” atrapa el calor.
La sangre fría que fluye
hacia los grandes músculos nadadores
pasa cerca de la sangre caliente
y deja a estos músculos en una red
especializada de vasos sanguíneos
llamada “rete mirabile”.
El calor “brinca” hacia la sangre fría
y se queda en el cuerpo.
Así, al atún rojo es una de las pocas
especies de peces de sangre caliente,
una gran ventaja en el medio marítimo.
Los animales de sangre fría
cuya temperatura corporal
depende por completo del ambiente
se hacen lentos en aguas frías.
El atún rojo es capaz de mantener calor
y así tener una visión más aguda,
puede procesar mejor la información
y nadar más rápido que su presa.
Vive en aguas frías,
profundas y subárticas.
Gracias a su sangre caliente,
sus poderosos músculos
y su forma de torpedo aerodinámico
con aletas que se pliegan
en cavidades para reducir la resistencia,
al atún rojo puede alcanzar velocidades
que otros animales no igualan.
Alcanza una velocidad máxima
de casi 65 km por hora,
por lo que supera
al gran tiburón blanco o la orca.
Incluso a su cómoda velocidad de crucero,
pueden cruzar el Atlántico
en un par de meses.
Nadar esas distancias requiere
de muchísimo oxígeno,
pero el atún rojo
está bien adaptado para ello.
Entre más rápido nada,
más agua pasa por sus agallas
y más oxígeno puede absorber del agua.
Esta necesidad
de un flujo constante de agua
obliga al atún a estar
siempre en movimiento.
Implica también que el atún rojo
no puede succionar a su presa
como hace la mayoría de los peces.
En cambio, debe perseguir
a su presa con la boca abierta.
Atrapan presas más pequeñas
que otros depredadores de su tamaño:
calamares, crustáceos
y peces más pequeños como el jurel.
Su habilidad para regular
la temperatura corporal
no solo lo hace un gran cazador:
le da un campo de acción casi ilimitado.
Tan pronto tiene fuerza
para nadar contra corriente,
el atún rojo deja las agua tibias
de su zona de desove
y pasa su vida cazando
por todo el océano Atlántico.
Los atunes del golfo de México
y del mar Mediterráneo
frecuentan las mismas
zonas de alimentación:
desde Brasil a Texas,
de Islandia a Senegal, y más lejos aún.
Pero cuando llega la hora
de reproducirse, como a los 10 años,
siempre regresan a su mar de origen.
Aquí, grupos de machos y hembras
liberan millones de huevos
y esperma al agua.
Migran de ida y vuelta
entre las zonas de alimento y desove
cada año por el resto de sus vidas.
El atún rojo del Atlántico puede vivir
más de 40 años, sin dejar de crecer.
Un espécimen grande es decenas
de millones de veces más pesado
que cuando nació.
El mismo gran tamaño que hace
a este atún indomable en el mar
también lo hace vulnerable
a un depredador particular: nosotros.
Los humanos tienen una larga historia
de pescar al atún del Atlántico,
que incluso está grabada
en antiguas monedas griegas.
Pero en décadas recientes,
la demanda se ha disparado,
pues el atún rojo se caza
para sashimi, sushi y filete de atún.
Un solo pescado llega a venderse
en  USD 10 000 o más,
lo que promueve
la pesca ilegal o sobrepesca.
Pero si los esfuerzos de conservación
se redoblan y se cumple el cupo permitido,
las poblaciones del atún rojo
pueden empezar a recuperarse.